getting involved in databases back in
the 80s when I was asked to port ingress
to exploit the best recommendations for
how do you set up a database is to set
them up directly on the wall partitions
put your log file on a separate disk and
only use the outer segments where it's
fastest and stripe or diversity a
tablespace across as many spindles as
you can find to try and get speed and
don't let any of the operating systems
buffer cache or buy off systems to get
in the way between your database engine
and your disks so that was the
recommendation but let's look at this
typical storage stack today it looks
something like this this is simplified
at the Baden even got your disks and
disks do all sorts of weird and
wonderful things inside and they remap
your your your requests so you don't
know whether if you take this block then
that block whether they're actually
going to be contiguous on the disk or
not you don't even know whether it's
gonna be the same unit because an SSD
could have lots of different flash cards
that it stripes things internally it's
made internally you've got no idea of
the topology inside your disk and on top
of that we put a RAID controller now may
or may not export the topology of the
underlying system to the next layer up
and then if you're the systems
administrator for an enterprise class
machine you're probably using a logical
volume manager on top of that which
again highlights the topology of the
things so it creates volumes that may or
may not be striped over multiple Veda
raids may or may not have caches
involved with a HD in there somewhere
and then you've got the page cache or
the buffer pool which I've put in as a
liability isn't really it sort of off to
the side and then you've got your file
systems on top of that and the VFS on
top of that and then a system called
layer and you put your database
management right at the top and it
doesn't know what the topology is
anymore so the user space
doesn't understand the disc a layout and
it can't optimize for it that could be a
good thing I mean maybe the colonel
knows better than the userspace how to
optimize stuff but database management
and file systems also can't see the dis
layout and exif s in particular really
wants to know how the discs are divided
up so it can optimize parallelism at the
lowest level so let's try turning it
upside down let's put a relational
database management system right at the
bottom directly on the disks which is as
close as we can get to the hard way but
fuse or something on the top because
database managers want to look at what
to talk to user space they don't wanna
talk to the colonel and if use let you
put a file system a user space and then
we can have all those other things on
top and let's see what's going on I want
you to do that for ages if you think
about what a file system actually is
it's a set of mappings it's a mapping
from a name to a set of metadata all the
ownership and file modes and all that
stuff that you you do when you do an LS
SL and it's a mapping from name to file
content in POSIX related systems we
don't have any funky file systems that
do in the exocrine chill access method
or anything like that that's assumed to
be done at user space the other place
that you've got a mapping is from name
to name for symbolic links so and
symbolically is just a mapping from the
name domain when we've got this in the
file system we want to order the writes
for consistency so you want to make sure
that you do things in the right order so
if you get a crash your fastest and can
still be understood the on this layout
could still be understood by the file
system when it comes up again we want to
make sure that writes to different files
are isolated from each other so that if
I write to this file it doesn't
interfere with the bytes to this file
and if possible your file system should
even make the performance not noticeable
so if you've got heavy might on this
file it shouldn't really affect the
speed advice in this other file and a
good file system will spread things
across the spindles it's got so you do
actually get some of that isolation and
the other thing you really want you
really really want to a power system is
if you call F sync on an open file when
that F sync
you know that it's a crash the data is
actually on permanent storage you can
get it back
I've had some file system
implementations where that's not true
and it's a bit annoying now if you think
about this this is exactly the standard
acid properties that the database has
got with the addition of atomic city
some file system operations have to be
atomic creating a link during a rename
you expect those to be atomic and
there's a few others too but the other
ones the ones we just talked about
they're just the acid things so let's
use a relational database management
system that handles replication perhaps
at the bottom level this makes it really
easy to add new attributes so maybe what
do to Apple like file system with a
resource fork or maybe we want to try
funky ACL mechanisms and you can do that
very easily
and because the database engine
guarantees consistency maybe we can
throw our way beneath the fsck ever and
if we use a relational database system
that handles replication for example
maybe a movie ODB would Calera
then you can get distribution for all
those three but it's a big battier most
of the modern relational database system
management systems we've got such as
Postgres rely on aspects of the file
system for their live operation they
don't run on more discs anymore
at least Postgres does i discovered only
last night by talking to one of them
mysql main taylor's who happens to be at
the conference but mysql you can
actually configure to do on war disks
but because i only found that out last
night i haven't tried it yet we anyway
i've been looking to do this for ages
that haven't had time one of the things
our group does we have a research group
of the university is every year we
invite good students to come and spend
the summer months with us embedded in a
research group and this year sam liter
and
and wanted to do this this task so he
started looking at what it would take to
put a relational database level what
tables schemas you'd need what queries
you'd need to be able to do the stuff
but while he was doing preliminary work
he discovered that it's already been
done this sounds like it's gonna be a
really short project mr. su casa
hammer no from Japan a michael vick
who's from somewhere up north but
currently lives in southeast asia
um created a thing called mysql FS back
in the early 2000s it hasn't been
touched since 2009
which means it doesn't compile with GCC
version 8 anymore that was fairly easy
to fix what it looks like
is this this is the schema you've got
three tables the tree table which Maps I
node to parent I node to name so it's
indexed on name and it's indexed on I
note so you can do a search on the I
know to find the name and you can do a
search on the name to find the I know
that already gives you something that's
better than most fastest ones cuz you
can't actually look up a names law firm
and I know it very easily and by joining
on I know to parent you can get
everything that's in a directory um
you've got the inodes table which
contains all the metadata except for the
number of links that a file has that's
gives you the modified time the creation
time the mode and two extra things
whether the inode is in use at the
moment and whether it's been deleted
because this file system doesn't track
in links you need to have a separate bar
flag to say that's been deleted you
can't delete things straight away
because they might be in use when in use
goes false and deleted goes false then
the I know can be removed and finally
you've got the data blocks data boxes
yes sir it's another table with 4k blobs
in it and a sequence number the sequence
number it's the
sequence of lumber of the fork a blob in
the files extent so the first four caves
got a sequence number of zero the next
one's got a sequence number of one and
so on and which I know de team and their
that's what you need to implement a
faster stone that's pretty nice doesn't
it
when you want to actually do a lookup
let's say I've got a name and I want to
convert that to an inode and all it
starts you get this really funky query
it's a self join on the parent I nodes
where you match the names of the parents
and you can do that in one query and get
all the results you want you don't
there's a sub query in the middle there
to cut out the number of links so you
can get in links at the same time this
ends up being quite expensive if you get
rid of that you double the speed of
bigquery but we'll come to that later
too so we've got this thing out of the
box and this is about three weeks ago we
got this working it's sort of passes the
plot excess weight except see time
updates to directories don't happen and
if you look up the the way that the
schemas work that makes sense because to
update a directory to add a new link all
you have to do is enter something into
the tree table and it doesn't touch the
inode table at all so let's see time
doesn't get updated in fact CLM almost
never gets updated but that was some
bugs and rename integrity checks
finding out whether a directory is empty
or not or even with the Rhino does it is
is a directory or a file is an expensive
check because you have to look at the
inode table not just the tree table
which meant that when you do a rename
over a non empty directory it does the
rename quite happily and all of the
files were in that directory become
orphans yeah
and not to use em else it turned out
that the version of fuse that was being
used only hoped single user so if you
try to access the file system as
somebody who wasn't the person who
mounted it it would give you all sorts
of weird min ever messages that didn't
match the POSIX standard for the system
calls you happen to be doing and that
really confused the test wait I can tell
you and he yeah long filenames silently
get truncated is 254 bit bytes not
twenty fifty five twenty fifty four
bytes and if you've got a path name
longer than 1024 it got truncated 2023
butts before it got passed the name I
which made the file seemed to disappear
sometimes and and all right
what about performance can we actually
get good performance with this
[Laughter]
it was rather slow this was on a slow
disk and it turned out to be mostly log
file writing to that slow disk and maybe
a DB slow this we didn't do any tuning
we just used everything out of the box
so let's get a faster disk we'll put a
machine in with an SSD this is a bit
better
40 times star the next service for
postmark postmarked by the way it's a
benchmark that creates rewrites and
deletes lots and lots and lots of small
files it's meant to emulate a busy mail
server running with a male deer type
back end and okay we've got to fix this
so let's move first a few computer
version two to fuse version three the
big difference between fuse version 2
and version 3 is that a lot more
operations the inode number is cached in
the fuse layer so instead of having to
do a lookup and that funky joy
every for every single system call we
could just use the cached version of the
inode that gets rid of an expensive
query for every for most every operation
also where we are all busy accessing the
inode table we all add in the see time
and M time updates get atra was which
which is essentially stat which is
called for every directory lookup and
for an awful lot of times things like
postmark are doing stat as well as open
or close and when you do a get int get
dense call a stat called it's called
internally to fill in the dentary buffer
but each time you go through team you
can get both at the same time internally
so we can reduce the number of queries
and get Etra by a factor of two because
it was doing two sets of queries the
first one to get the most of the
attributes and the second one to get the
size with a sip foot query on the data
blocks table by caching that inside the
inode firstly it meant that we had to do
an update to the inode after a right
which meant we could update the modify
time and secondly admit we didn't have
to do another scan of the data blocks
every time we did a stack to get the
size so that's pretty good I fixed the
rename problem and fused version 3 it's
got two extra flags you can use when you
set up the view system allow user which
gives you multi-user and use I know
which meant that we could get all these
this caching going popping so that was a
lot of work that we did we've still got
some non POSIX semantics dot and dot dot
in every directory um aren't really
there they're just added in when you
could do the get dense call which means
that they're not as they're not really
there they don't contribute to in links
which meant that you'll find
optimizations that say anything that's
only got two links must be an empty
directory definite doesn't work and C
times still want updated on directory
and directories always have zero size
because they know they don't have any
content except in the tree table and
that BFS isn't implemented really
and there's also refused bug somewhere
if we now and then if you use the fuse
mounted file system with this thing um
and you type sync it hangs and the only
way to fix that is to reboot the machine
but now with all of this
we're only 9 times slower than extra
bits of paper and leaden writes only 7
times slower than NFS and about 10 times
slower than exists but super utilization
is through and a half times higher
mostly in the database engine to give
you an idea git clone on the Linux
source tree can pit comparative leaks or
next to fierce it's real time of 9
minutes 23 minutes on lowest relevance
but if you look at the use of in system
time it's comparable that's because the
CPU time used by the database management
system is much much higher and so that
that's where all the times going the
worst offenders I create rename unlink
right and stack which are using git atra
internally and does all that funky joins
in order to find all the end links if we
cache in links we should be able to get
faster also we're doing 3 queries for
every block bitten we do one to see
whether that block is already in the
dirt in the database and if it's not we
inserted then one to update the contents
of that and then one to update the
inodes see time and size we could
probably get stats down to one query per
block written and one query per byte
just by updating the sides at the end
instead of at the beginning instead of
every block right and
expensive loss of some atomicity so
that's more stuff that we can do we
could also cache the type and the mode
which the only two bits of the of the I
know that you actually need in forget
dense in the in the tree table we do
also cache recent the years I notes and
double the block size which would reduce
by half the number of queries but
there's all these new things that's
possible to we can use replication that
works we tried it out it does give you a
slowdown because you've got to do a
three pace commit as soon as you've got
replication on the database
it adds the network delays plus the
commit time for the remote disk onto
whatever you're doing so it does slow
things down a lot we can also do a fast
find find over file system at the moment
has to do a recursive descent and match
all of attributes that just becomes a
database query and databases are really
fast as that stuff from our five-minute
query to scan and print out all the
names it becomes like a point one second
query to print out all the names if you
just do it directly through SQL if we
add an index on the content we can do
full-text searches if they seek a I said
we didn't need it but if you do need it
you can write one that's really fast and
it's easy to add other features like
resource box you can get at the moment
from github pull requests welcome it
more or less works performance isn't too
painful I think it's actually quite a
useful platform for experimenting with
other faster some things and it's also a
good exercise in optimization techniques
if you want to make it faster and pull
the quests welcome ok have you got any
questions yeah at the back can we get a
mic up there please
that's one at the back in the middle
I've got to ask this one have you then
installed a database onto the I would
love to try that at some point but I
haven't done it yet because I would be
interested to see how poorly that
performs yes I'd be interested to see
where the semantics are maintained all
the way up and down other questions just
why because it's called crack yeah have
you tried looking at doing like sort of
an inline blog for sort of small files
because usually they're stored within
the block of the row so if you had like
small things especially something like
postmark and I think it's up to seven
sixty eight bytes for an OTB can be
stored in line so it would be that one
operation when you go and do the stat
you'd get it's a good good idea pull the
Questor welcome have you considered the
more traditional falsa model where you
move to tree into the inode the problem
with moving the tree into the inodes you
lose the multi way mapping from name to
I note so you can't have more than one
link to a file then is there any other
database engine other than my sequel
suitable for doing this would it be
better as is a or is this deep in the my
single engine we started with MySQL
because we already had the code as a
starting point you could do it with any
database as it turns out my SQL you can
talk directly to the hard disk so that's
gonna be the next thing we try because
I'd like to get rid of the faster some
layer as part of the problem perhaps but
yeah give it an that give it a go you
can use anything with SQL at the moment
anymore okay as I said pull request
welcome have fun
you
we're going to have